there's a real sense of crisis uh here
this evening particularly over
the travel ban not just here but
throughout whitehall
now number 10 has announced that the
prime minister will chair a cobra
meeting tomorrow
to discuss the situation regarding
international travel particularly
the steady flow of freight in and out of
the uk
there's going to be further meetings
this evening tomorrow morning to ensure
what number 10 calls
robust plans are in place now the big
fear here
is over freight if freight is not being
able to come in and out
we are told that is very serious the
government is actively
tracking how many days food is left on
the supermarket shelves
if the ports shut some food stuffs will
run out
that is the big fear now um
tory mps are very unhappy about this uh
they
are saying that the prime minister needs
to get a grip that's roger gale a kent
mp
and also on brexit uh nicholas sturgeon
is now saying
it's imperative that the prime minister
seeks an agreement to extend
the brexit transition period and
because she's talking about a profoundly
serious situation
and it would be unconscionable to
compound it with brexit she says
the labour party's rachel reeves
is calling on the prime minister to get
a grip and as we've heard grant shaps is
telling people not to go to those
channel ports a real sense of crisis
here critics will say the government has
been slow to react
uh but uh the prime minister clearly
wants to get a grip tomorrow
starting with a cobra meeting which
they'll obviously
top of the agenda is the threat to food
supplies